- Okay, what do we want to talk about?
Couple things.
The first thing that I want
to talk about is perception.
Something I've become unbelievably
fascinated with recently
is this binary thing of basically,
and we've heard it our whole lives
half glass full, half glass empty,
like, I've become unbelievably fascinated
with are you sitting in
this audience right now
and realizing that this
is the greatest era
to be alive in the human race?
(audience cheering)
Or are you consuming
content that makes you think
shit's terrible and fucked
up and everything sucks shit?
(audience laughing)
And it's probably somewhere in between.
But for me, in the context
of where I want to take
my talk, which is the
business opportunities,
the life opportunities, I think it's
a remarkable time to be alive.
This right here is the remote
control of our society.
A lot of people don't like
that, and I respect that.
You don't like that when you go out
everybody's on their phones,
you think your kids are getting fucked up.
I get it.
(audience chuckling)
But the reality of the situation is this.
This device and its
interaction on the internet
is really a remarkable thing.
I am blown away that every
person in this audience
has so much more upside to
achieve than ever before
strictly because of the internet.
Every person in this room,
every person at this conference right now,
including myself, is grossly
underestimating the internet
because we're living
through the beginning of it
and it's hard to calibrate it
and realize how big of a deal it is.
But the second you start
contextualizing this platform,
things will start getting different,
especially if you're in
a place where you've got
the mindset that this is
optimism and opportunity.
And that's just where I'm at.
I basically can't wrap my head around
how easy it is right
now to garner attention
and then deploy that attention
to be the governor of Colorado,
sell t-shirts, sell books,
sell your insurance practice,
list a home and sell it.
The bottom line is no
matter what you do here,
no matter what you do here,
the one thing that binds
all of us is that we're all
battling for attention from somebody
and then we get the opportunity
to tell them what we do.
Once you understand that
attention is the currency
that we're all chasing,
then we can start having
a much smarter conversation about this.
Watch this, and I think
a lot of people here
will learn from this.
How many people here, and
I know a lot of you know,
I know a lot of you
follow me enough to know
I like this if you follow me,
but just by show of hands,
and don't get lazy on me,
how many people here have run Facebook ads
and it didn't work for them?
Raise your hands.
Actually, can we do this again?
How many, if you just
raised your hand everywhere,
I want you to stand up.
Stand up.
Don't get lazy.
I'm gonna give you one more second.
Stand up if you've run Facebook
ads and they did not work.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
Denver, these people suck.
(audience laughing)
I'm kidding, kidding,
kidding, kidding, kidding.
Thank you for standing up.
Sit down.
Here's why I wanted to show you that,
and here's the point
I'm gonna try to make,
and here's a tactical breakthrough
that I would like to accomplish.
Knowing Robert, and Tony, and
other people are speaking,
I think we could talk a lot
about theoretical frameworks,
and motivation, and mindset,
and I believe in that shit the most.
I think optimism is the
most practical strategy
in the game and I believe in that.
But on of the things I
wanted to fill the void of
in this schedule today
is to get you to leave
with one or two practical
things that actually
make an impact on whatever
that you're trying to achieve.
That number one thing
that I can do for you
on that practical impact is to
get you to finally understand
why it is super important that almost 70%
of this audience stood up and that delta
is where all the opportunity is.
Let me explain.
Facebook ads on May,
what are we, nine, 10,
on May 10th, 2018, is the
single best advertising product
known to man.
It is so grossly under-priced
that the only thing
that I've ever lived
through that is similar
is early Google AdWords.
If I was speaking in 2003, in
2004 about what I was doing
for my dad's business at the time,
I would have asked the
same question right now.
The only difference is,
I would have asked people
to stand up if they've run Google AdWords
and it hasn't worked for them.
And the same amount of
people would have stood up.
Meanwhile, in that five to six year period
of the early days of Google AdWords,
the number one advertiser on the platform
is a small company called Amazon.
Amazon used Google's unbelievably
under-priced attention.
And to give you guys context,
when I was running ads
on day one on Google for Wine Library,
I was buying wine terms like
the word wine and pinot grigio
for five and 10 cents a click.
Those words went on to be worth
$3, and $4, and $12 a click.
Attention, much like real
estate and every other product
is about supply and demand.
This is the attention platform.
Social media is the places that we deploy
our attention within it.
I believe that right now
this Facebook arbitrage
is the single, most coherent
thing that everybody
in this audience can take advantage of.
But here's the problem.
If you don't know how to do it,
you're not gonna get the value
of the under-priced attention.
A lot of people just stood up.
When I made that joke these people suck,
there was a little truth
in that sucky statement.
(audience chuckling)
It's not that they actually suck,
it's that their execution on
that Facebook campaign sucked.
(audience chuckling)
The ROI of any execution is
predicated on your skill.
The ROI of a basketball to me is zero.
The ROI of a basketball for LeBron James
is gonna end up being billions of dollars.
People make decisions
that things don't work
because it didn't work for them.
It doesn't mean that it doesn't work.
I promise you, and I'm
making this statement
in a very selfish way so
that I'm putting it on film
so I can recall it in
eight years when I'm trying
to get you to do AR, or voice,
or AI, or something else,
I'm gonna point to this video.
Because in seven years, all the
articles are gonna say this:
nobody spent enough money on
Facebook during its heyday
between 2013 and 2020.
When the biggest companies
in the world figure out
how good Facebook advertising really is,
Coca-Cola, and Coors Light,
and all the biggest brands
in the world are gonna
start spending their money
in the platform, which
is gonna kick you guys
out of the feed because spending $8
to get in front of 1,000
people is gonna start costing
$150 to get in front of 1,000 people.
And more importantly,
we're gonna stop converting
on those ads as much as we do now
because we're gonna be used to them
and it's always cat and mouse.
New advertising comes
out, we convert on it,
it gets mature, we run away from it.
Excuse me for one second.
Bro, thanks for wearing the Jets shirt.
Fucking love you.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
The number one thing that
I would like to accomplish
in this talk today is
to get every person here
to go home and Google
how do I run Facebook ads
for a concrete manufacturer.
How do I sell cattle on Facebook?
How do I sell homes on Facebook?
I want you to go home
and read or watch videos
from anywhere between seven and 15 hours
over the next week and
then spend $5, $10, $50,
or $10 million, I don't know your business
or your economics, but if I compel you
to this truth that I know is real
and you decide to do it,
the one thing I'm scared of
is you're gonna go back
home and you're gonna
get your 21-year-old niece to do it
because she gets that technology shit.
I am so tired of people saying
that they didn't grow up
with this and it's not of their generation
and that they didn't know how to use it,
when it literally takes
five to seven hours
of putting education
time in to figure it out.
To have the audacity to say that you're 49
and you didn't grow up with it
or 64 and you didn't grow up with it,
if you're still in the game,
put in the fucking work.
(audience cheering)
I mean, people running businesses
and don't have six
hours to read, and test,
and try to figure out?
Guys, this is called communication.
It's how everything works.
There's a reason when
there's a coup d'etat
in a country that the first thing they do
is they go after the media
company to pump propaganda
into the citizens' minds.
Coms, marketing, communication,
if you are not relevant
on Facebook, and Instagram,
and LinkedIn, and Twitter,
and YouTube right now, you are irrelevant.
Period.
You don't like it?
Me either.
Tough shit, dick.
(audience laughing)
I don't care that you
miss the good old days
when the kids went outside and played.
They don't do that anymore.
(audience chuckling)
Sorry.
There's a ton of shit that you don't do
that your fucking grandma wished you did
back in the day too.
(audience laughing)
Holding onto ideology and
using that to run your business
is a losing formula.
Being romantic of how you
want it to be in the world
and then not affecting
your business in the way
that it actually is, is a vulnerability.
We are living through the
advancement of technology.
Technology is not gonna stop advancing
'cause you don't like what it's doing.
And meanwhile, what's really happening
is you say you don't like what it's doing
but you're living it the other way.
There's a bunch of
hypocrisy in the system.
And most importantly, even
if you don't use technology
'cause you're a fucking hippie,
(audience chuckling)
if you're in this audience,
you're trying to figure something out.
Right?
You're trying to win.
You're putting in the work.
This is game over.
Because, and this is why
I'm passionate about it.
How many people here are
retiring in the next 10 years?
And I don't mean you're
gonna fucking crush it
and buy an island.
(audience chuckling)
I mean you're just really
fucking old and you're finished.
(audience laughing)
10 years, show me.
Okay.
So for the 40 of you, cool.
You can take some of
this with a grain of salt
even though I think
it's relevant right now.
But let me make a promise to all of you
of why this really matters.
The reason you have to become
great at Facebook advertising,
at Instagram influencer advertising,
at starting a podcast, in
understanding how to do
white papers on LinkedIn,
not spamming and selling,
branding and marketing, the
reason you have to figure out
this stuff, the reason you
have to be comfortable with it
is technology is just starting.
If you think it's crazy now,
where do you think this is going?
Did anybody watch Google's
presentation the other day?
Yesterday?
Did you guys see this presentation?
Right?
I mean, an assistant that understands
the nuances and context of a human voice?
Like, literally, Google
yesterday showed you
that anybody in the world who's an admin
or an assistant right now is out of a job.
Yeah.
And so my question to you is if you're not
putting in the work to understand
how these social networks work,
how the hell are you gonna be living
in the world that's coming
next in augmented reality,
and VR, and AI, and machine
learning, and block chain?
Like, we're not going backwards, guys.
Like, we're not gonna
all of a sudden wake up
in a couple weeks and
be like you know what,
fuck it, let's go back to
farming and fucking go that way.
(audinece laughing)
- [Audience Member] I am a farmer.
- Farming is amazing, bro.
But you're the only fucking farmer here.
(audinece laughing)
Cool, and three others.
I get it.
But guess what, awesome, I'm so pumped
there's fucking 19 farmers here,
but if this was fucking 1897,
we'd all be fucking farmers.
Get it?
That's the point, right?
And the best part is, when you
use technology and branding,
I've got a farming friend
right now who's like,
fuck, it's getting tighter.
I'm like, bro, instead of
just selling your crops,
why don't you start a brand
on Amazon and Shopify,
use Facebook and Instagram
and now all of a sudden,
your fucking peas are the
fucking coolest peas on earth.
(audience chuckling)
(audience cheering)
It's true.
Guys, this is very simple.
I'm gonna say something
that I don't want to say
because I don't want to hurt your feelings
and I have no, I don't know
you, but I do want to say this.
I need you to hear this from me.
Around this conference,
it's important to me.
Please understand something
that I'm fascinated by
and I'm hoping one person
hears me and it's the time
they needed to hear it.
Consuming my content, coming
to conferences like this,
reading more books, debating
about the way the world
should be, being a
perfectionist, debating,
complaining, dwelling, all
of it excuses for not doing.
If you ask me what I really
want, I want this to be
the last conference you ever go to.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
I, I want you to understand
that it is very likely
that if you're sitting here,
you are trying to find ways not to do.
That's not everybody.
That might not even be most.
But even if one person here uses
reading 87 fucking mindset
and motivation books
and listening to 44 fucking podcasts,
and 13 fucking blogs, and
coming to nine fucking things
like this a year, if even one
person here is doing that,
and by the way, there's a
lot more than one person here
doing that, it's (audience chuckling)
yeah, you're laughing 'cause
you know it's fucking true.
'Cause you know it's fucking true, right?
How many more fucking books
do these people need to read?
(audience laughing)
It comes down to doing.
You can figure out how
to market your business
to accomplish all your
fucking goals in life
whether that's to build
a pool in your backyard
or to buy the fucking jets,
whatever it is in between,
if you're actually willing
to put in the work.
You know what I do?
I fucking work 15 hours a day.
I fucking write my
captions on my Instagram.
I reply to your fucking DMs.
I answer comments.
I read my email.
It's fucking work.
You want the secret?
It's called work.
(audience cheering)
And by the way, do not get confused here.
You have to work to match the ambition
coming out of your mouth.
This is not about working 15 hours a day.
You got family, you've
got other interests.
You do you, but don't
be a fucking hypocrite.
Don't be full of shit.
Don't tell me you're buying
a fucking private jet
when you're watching four
hours of YouTube videos a day.
'Cause it's work.
You have to figure out what
you're trying to achieve
and what you want and then
you need to put in the work
that maps to that ambition.
And I know somebody's
sitting here and be like,
yeah, Gary, you talk about
hard work, but I work smart.
I work smart too and hard.
Now what, dick?
(audience laughing)
This is not a debate.
The most controllable thing, listen,
we're all built differently, right?
We've all got different skills,
different charisma
levels, different beauty,
different smarts, we've
all got different shit,
but the most controllable
thing in this room,
the most controllable thing
is putting in the work.
We, especially the
people in this conference
including myself, we are so fortunate.
We are so entitled.
There is so much abundance in the system.
When I see other people
try to drag people down
and razz on them for their success,
it makes me laugh because
they don't realize
how much abundance is in the system.
There's nobody, not your
most direct competitor,
I don't give a shit if
you have a flower shop
on this side of the street and literally
on the other side of the
street there's a flower shop,
nobody's taking any
money out of your pocket.
You're taking money out of your pocket.
(audience cheering)
It's true.
So this is a mindset game for me, right?
Are you on offense and
realize all this rant
that I just did for four minutes?
And if you do, cool, comma, let's move on.
Facebook, Instagram.
Let me tell you why I'm saying it.
It's 'cause I'm bitter.
When he was talking up here and said,
first of all, who wrote my bio?
That was like my mom.
That was the longest, fucking shit.
(audience laughing)
Fuck.
I was getting pissed.
I was like, I was like this guy's a dick.
(audience chuckling)
Anyway, when I was listening to that bio
when he was saying, "and
he built his dad's business
"from a $4 to $60 million business,"
I was sitting back there
and I'm like, "Loser."
And here's why I said it.
I figured out Google
AdWords the day it came out.
I understood that search
engines were gonna be big
because the internet was crazy
and Yahoo'd already become big.
It was real.
I understood that we would
all use search engines
for a long time.
Showing up first for very
few pennies was a good idea.
I started running them day one.
It worked.
You typed in wine, Wine
Library showed up first.
You clicked it, you
weren't used to it yet.
They didn't even blue it out back then.
You weren't even sure
you were hitting ads.
It was fucking gangster shit.
(audience laughing)
Every sixth person bought something.
I was paying 30 cents
for new fucking customers
and it's sitting in my fucking face
and my business is going
from three, to seven,
to 15, to 29 in my fucking face.
And what did I do?
I was still doing direct mail.
I was still doing TV.
I was still doing billboards.
Which was fine 'cause
it wasn't as overpriced
as it is today, but I fucking hit oil
and I wasn't pumping hard enough.
When he said four to 60, my brain goes
should have been 250.
If all the profits I was
making that I was spending
on other things I put back into Google,
it would have been 250.
My friends, it's not too
late for Facebook advertising
and Instagram influencers.
It's not.
Is it as good as it was 36 months ago?
It is not.
Is it a hell of a lot
better than it's gonna be
in 36 month?
It is.
And it is that scale.
There's nothing you do,
and I love that somebody's
sitting here and saying
yeah, but it doesn't work for my industry.
Bullshit.
It is for your industry.
The whole country is on it.
Oh, but Gary, young kids aren't on it.
Fine.
I understand.
But when I run ads for 18
to 24 year olds on Facebook,
we sell the living shit out of it.
Are they on it as much?
No.
Are they amortized out to Instagram?
Yes.
Does Facebook own Instagram?
Should you do influencer
marketing on Instagram?
Yes, 'cause people don't
know how to price themselves.
If you find people at 100,000 followers
and you ask them to post
a picture of your thing
or tell them about your thing on DM,
a lot of times they over price
and a lot of times they under price.
You're gonna kiss some frogs,
but there's a fuck load
of princes right now.
I'm telling you guys,
I'm tell you right now,
take the audacity, the lack of education,
the laziness out of your system
and become a practitioner
in Facebook advertising and
Instagram influencer marketing
and it will disproportionately
help your business.
Don't know what to say and do?
Figure it out.
That's your job.
You want the fruits and
the benefits of winning?
You gotta put in the work.
You gotta lose some money.
You gotta win some money.
You gotta read some shit.
You gotta try some shit.
But here's the thing.
You don't have to spend a lot to learn.
You can run $100 worth of ads
and look at what it teaches you.
But know this.
The world is broken up into two places
when it comes to this:
sellers and marketers.
Most people are sellers.
So they're gonna spend $1,000
and they're gonna expect
some sort of transaction to come from it
in the short term and they're
gonna deem it not a success.
The key is to understand
how to build a brand
on these platform so that
the business comes to you
or there's a halo effect, a
waterfall from the marketing.
My personal belief over
the last two decades
is to bring the most value.
I always tell people don't
listen to what I'm saying,
watch what I do.
I pump out ungodly amounts of
content for free every day.
I engage with my community every day.
I'm not doing this for my
health or kicks and giggles.
I'm doing it 'cause I want
to win a fucking Superbowl.
Do you understand?
I believe that the people
that give the most value,
do you know how weird it was
when I started Wine Library TV in 2006?
I did a YouTube show for
the yous that don't know.
I really kind of broke
out in the mid 2000s
'cause of YouTube.
I started the YouTube show and I would sit
in front of a camera,
drink four bottles of wine
for 20 minutes, and hundreds of thousands
of people watched it.
It was great.
Anyway,
(audience laughing)
I would sell these wines at my wine store
and I would sit there
and I would pan them.
I would drink it and say it
was light and off balanced
and a piece of shit and
you shouldn't drink it.
Wines that I was selling from vendors
who were my partners.
The reason I did that
was the people in here
that realize the actual game, which is,
in a world of the internet
where there's an abundance
of free information, the people
that bring the most value
to the audience win.
The people who can give
away the best information
for free wins.
For you to give away
your secrets for free,
you're gonna learn two things.
Number one, there is abundance.
But you're gonna learn something else.
When you give away your
best advice for free,
99% of people aren't gonna
do anything about it.
I am gonna sit here, and I'm sitting here
for 34 minutes pounding for people
to go home and do five hours of homework
and 10 days of testing
to fundamentally unlock
real growth in their
business, and 98% of you
fuck faces aren't gonna do it.
(audience laughing)
That's life.
And there's nothing I can do about it.
But it doesn't make it any less true.
It's coming.
This golden goose, like
Google was for five years,
Google now is good.
Google's fine.
Google AdWords is solid.
If you're good at it and you
put a lot of work into it,
you can find your pockets.
It's nice.
It's appropriately priced.
One more demonstration with standing up
and this is gonna really tie the bow
of why I want you to run out of here
and go start attacking this.
How many people here
outside of live sports
now mainly watch OTTs, Netflix,
Hulu, Amazon, HBO Prime,
stand up, Apple TV, stand up
if you now mainly watch those.
I want everybody to see this.
This is, yeah, wow is right.
Keep standing up.
Do not go down.
This is massively, this
is thesis of my energy
of this conversation.
We can all agree that
this is not a high school
or a junior high, right, aged group?
We can now agree that us
older folk watch Netflix too.
Cool?
You can sit down since 90-fucking
percent of you stood up.
My friends, ABC, and NBC,
and CBS are out of business
as we know them.
Television commercial
industry is $80 billion.
$80 billion this year on
making and distributing
30- and 15-second videos that are played
in between TV shows and nobody's watching.
92% of the Fortune 500
companies in the CPG space,
consumer package goods,
Cheerios, Cool Whip,
Hellmann's, this lipstick, that lipstick,
that cereal, that soda,
93% of them declined
over the last two years.
Why?
'Cause they pour all their
money into commercials.
We've got another 24 to 36
months and then the ceiling
and the floor is gonna break
and all that money is
going to go into Facebook.
Mark my fucking words.
You have about 24 to 48
months to buy up real estate
of attention for whatever you do.
Sell hats, you're a
lawyer, you sell insurance,
I don't care what you do,
it is grossly under-priced.
Because you're first
half-ass effort of $1,000
or $10,000 didn't work, doesn't
mean it's not under-priced.
It means that you had their attention
but your picture or video sucked
shit and nobody watched it
or did anything about it.
Cool?
Go figure out how not to suck shit.
(audience chuckling)
Because in 36 and 48 months
when all this money comes in,
it will become properly priced,
just like Google did,
and then there may not be
anything else for us
people, us normal folk
who don't have $8 billion in money
to be able to compete
for America's attention.
Got it?
This, May fucking 10th, where
the internet's the middle man,
where the internet is smoking out
all the bad people in
our society and finally
exposing them, thank god,
this, May 10th, right now,
the internet is the middle man
and it doesn't care that your
parents were drug addicts,
and it doesn't care
that you got Ds and Fs,
and it doesn't care what your
grand pappy did 40 years ago.
It's agnostic.
It doesn't give a fuck.
It rewards you if you
put in the right work
and do it the right
way and it shits on you
if you don't.
Do you understand?
(audience cheering)
If you do, that means you
understand what I understand,
which is this is one of the first times
in the history of the
human race where merit
is being fully rewarded.
(audience cheering)
And if you really, really understand
what I just said, it would
make you get your ass up
right now, run home, and start working.
How, how you could be
letting this pass you by
during this moment baffles
me once you become educated.
It's one thing if you didn't see it.
It's one thing if you couldn't
put the pieces together.
Listen.
Manhattan was for sale a long time ago.
There's a lot of people that
decided to buy other things
instead of acres of Manhattan.
They missed it.
Facebook was 20 bucks a share.
I bought.
You didn't.
There's moments.
Please understand this.
The attention of the
human race is available
for under-priced dollars.
If you can grab it, whatever you're up to,
you want to be the mayor of your town,
you want to sell eight more homes,
you want to build a big
pizza delivery business,
whatever you're up to will
disproportionately scale
when you buy under-priced attention
and you get people to
know what you're up to,
and what you do, and what value you bring.
This is special.
This is a magical era
and you will regret it
if you don't deploy all of
your efforts against it.
And so while you debate that
it's not for your industry,
while you sit around and think about
what other people are
gonna think about you
if you make that content
or if the lighting's good,
or you don't like your left
side of your fucking face,
or whatever the fuck you think,
while you do all that debating,
people are grabbing up this opportunity.
I highly recommend, my
friends, for you to become
a practitioner not a headline
reader of the current state
of the internet.
It's called social
networks on the cell phone.
It's also called podcasts
on podcast networks,
it's vlogging on YouTube,
it's writing long-form
articles on LinkedIn.
And maybe your industry is
boring by your standards,
but it's still your industry
and if you could be the queen
or king of your industry,
then you win.
And the way to do that
in 2018 is to be a person
that knows how to make pictures, videos,
audio clips, and written
words on seven platforms.
It's simple as shit.
My friends, I am not a big-time genius.
I'm simple.
I care about one thing.
Your attention.
Your ears and your eyes are my religion.
I watch were you go.
I watch you saying you're
not gonna go there.
You know how many people here
said they would never be
on Instagram and now are?
You know how many people
here when they got
the first emoji said what
the fuck is this shit
(audience laughing)
who now send poop emojis 24 hours a day?
Some of the older cats in here said
they would never get a cell phone
because their fucking
pager was good enough.
(audience chuckling)
The cat's out of the bag.
We're not going back.
And you need to understand
that social norms are changing.
Online dating 12 years
ago, weird and creepy.
Today, the establishment.
Could you imagine if I stood
up here eight years ago
and said in eight years all
the parents in this room
are gonna want their children
to go into a stranger's car
'cause they're gonna think that's safer
than them driving themselves?
Do you know that all
across America right now
if you have enough net
worth, if you're rich,
that the big gift for a 16 or 17 year old
is unlimited Uber, not a new car?
They want their 16-year-old
daughter at 11:00 at night
to go into a stranger's
car every day of the week.
I would have been laughed off stage
if I would have pitched
you that idea 10 years ago.
Social norms are breaking
in front of our eyes.
The internet is the biggest
invention in the human race.
It is.
It's changed everything and
it's going to change everything.
And so I implore you to be so
grateful that you're actually
navigating through this time of abundance.
So you're more than welcome
to watch two or three
antiquated news stations who
tell you the world sucks shit
or you can watch what's
actually happening,
which is this is the greatest
fucking era to ever be alive.
People are living longer,
healthier, better,
and there's nothing but opportunity,
and nobody can stop you
except your lack of education,
or your entitlement,
or being fucking lazy.
Stop.
(audience cheering and applauding)
My friends,
the current scientifical,
mathematical odds
of being born are 400 trillion to one.
Like, your mom might have got up
and got another glass of wine.
(audience laughing)
400 trillion to one.
You're more likely to
win the Mega Millions
nine times in your life than
you are to even have a life.
I like data.
That's data.
We've got one life.
Do something about it.
Thank you.
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
Thank you.
- [Man] Give him a hand!
Gary Vaynerchuk!
Give him a hand, Denver!
- [Gary] Thank you.
Thank you, Denver.
- [Man] Gary V.